apple déterminer sa conférence
développeurs le dab à dubaï où d'ici
2019 avec pas mal d'annoncés logiciel
viendront ce matériel et une annonce
intéressante à leur prégnance destinée
pour le grand public sera plus une
annonce destinée aux professionnels mais
c'est quand même relativement cool j'ai
passé tout mon temps à prendre des
petites notes sur plein de petits
papiers jetés plein de trucs et je vous
faire un petit débrief globale pour
essayer de voir un petit peu mais ce que
j'en pense quelle manière j'ai ressenti
un peu cette cette présentation
[Musique]
il n'y a rien eu de gros effets whaou
il ya des annonces plus forte que
d'autres mais le truc qui n'a je dirais
le plus interpellé le plus intéressant
c'est le fait qu'ils aient un vrai os
qui arrive sur l'ipad une vraie
différenciation par rapport à ios
eyeos laïos pour ipad ça c'est
intéressant ça permettra de faire pas
mal de choses aller plus loin au niveau
de l'expérience de l'ipad
ça me paraît vraiment bien c'est le gros
gros gros point fort à côté de ça on n'y
a plus dans des améliorations dans des
mises à jour dans des nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui arrive que ce soit
pour l'apple white que ce soit du côté
de mac os des os
on est vraiment dans la surveiller une
évolution globale des produits mais pas
sur un truc un peu agron effet whaou
après forcément ce qu'on va rechercher
avec un événement comme le diabète ou
d'abeille ou 10,6 et la conférence des
développeurs lié à apple
on s'attend pas à voir vraiment des
grosses révolutions mais on voit arriver
de nouveaux produits de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui paraissent somme
toute assez logique et souvent des
fonctionnalités qu'on a déjà vu chez les
développeurs tiers que apple prend pour
elle et intègre de façon native alors on
va commencer tout de suite dans le côté
de tv ou est ce un truc assez assez
intéressant apple a déjà présenté il ya
quelques mois de nouveaux services
là ils ont refait un peu un focus dessus
et puis surtout ils ont vraiment annoncé
tv au s1 tvos qui sera multi
utilisateurs où vous aurez de la vidéo
pour tout aussi apple musique apple a4
dessus on voit que apple va vraiment à
les déployer son côté services notamment
avec eux sa solution de cloud gaming
apple cherche vraiment à se positionner
sur le cloud gaming il ya pas mal
d'acteurs qui arrivent dessus mais il
n'y a pas un acteur qui est hyper
implantés et qui est difficile à à
bouger le cloud gaming commence à se
développer et va continuer à se
développer dans les années à venir
a contrario une solution comme netflix
on peut plus dur à faire bouger les
lignes
apple va aussi voir sur ses
plates-bandes avec ce serait sans fin il
ya pas mal de choses très intéressantes
on arrive ensuite sur wake forest watch
obèses qui fait un peu peau neuve de
nouvelles fonctionnalités on a du
streaming audio directement dessus en
natif sans forcément passer par votre
iphone en gros votre apple wayne va être
plus indépendante plus autonomes et va
se passer petit à petit votre iphone en
tout cas peut potentiellement se passer
petit à petit votre iphone on voit
l'arrivée d'un magasin dédié d'un
appstore dédié pour l'apple watch why
not ça peut être intéressant
on a aussi toute la partie
santé qui continue à évoluer notamment
de la santé à long terme avec les
politiques traînent vous allez pouvoir
voir un petit peu et bien là vous avez
été bon un peu moins bons pour avoir une
vision globale sans autre activité au
niveau de votre sport en tout cas c'est
intéressant c'est toute la partie cycle
menstruel pour connaître l'état de vote
6 à s'exciter sur des applications
tierces c'est bien qu'apple les il a
aussi et en plus
effectivement ils ont enfin repris en
disant on le met dans la boîte mais pas
que vous l'aurez également dans le
prochaine à lloris on voit que du point
de vue de watchou s
c'est une évolution mais ya rien de bien
bien d'agde l'arrivée d'ayo s13 et
l'arrivée notamment du dark void alors
le dark mode on retrouve déjà les
dernières sur macos mojave on retrouve
un peu de retard gauche il arrive sur
ios ça peut être intéressant à se
permettre de gagner notamment à plus
d'autonomie au niveau des iphone parce
que comme on est sur des écrans oled
chanson tous notamment à l'iphone 10
aces et 10 s max un écran lorsque vous
avez un pixel noir c'est un pixel qui
est un donc ça veut dire moins
énergivore avec le dark mode voudrait
pouvoir gagner quand même un peu peur
autonomie année aux os qui va toujours
plus vite toujours plus performants avec
pas mal d'applications revu et corrigé
safari mail toute la partie note maps
qui continue à se réinventer aller plus
loin ça c'est aussi ce truc est
vachement intéressant la géolocalisation
il ya en gros focus de fait par apple
sur la sécurité de vos données sur le
fait qu'il ne vous traquent pas au
niveau de votre géolocalisation est
justement ils ont profité pour aller un
petit peu taclé facebook et google en
disant effectivement nous on ne vous
traquent pas vos informations sont hyper
sécurisé et justement il parle notamment
du petit bouton pour se connecter se
connecter via facebook se connecter via
google en dix ans les éditeurs en face
peuvent récupérer vos données avec nous
c'est strictement impossible ils ont
créé le bouton s'identifier avec apple
vous pourrez faire soit choix d'envoyer
vous votre email
ils ont accès à votre vraie email pour
vous connecter en direct soit de passer
par un email unique par application
apple comme ça il sera strictement
impossible pour les éditeurs tiers
d'avoir accès à votre email et ainsi
vous donner seront protégés on voit
vraiment la guerre continue à voir lui
entre facebook google et apple notamment
son côté de la vie privée la donnée
personnelle ça c'est intéressant
également jean-louis en avant bien
évidemment on quitte avec toujours plus
de sécurité notamment au niveau de la
caméra de surveillance les vidéos et
audio seront cryptées sécurisées dans le
cloud d'apple
même apple n'aura pas accès à vos
données il travaille avec netapp mot
logitech et compagnie pour le côté cas
et à ils ont fait également un focus sur
l'application messages qui revu corrigé
et la nouvelle pour souhaiter bon ça je
vous le passez des animaux jimi hendrix
sont plus personnalisé qui vont tenir
compte du contexte un truc un petit
frigo dans vos photos vous allez pouvoir
modifier l'intensité de l'éclairage dans
mode portrait vous allez pouvoir les
éditer modifier la saturation une autre
lumière ça fait pas mal de petites
éditions pouvait faire dans lightroom
pour smartphones vous pouvez également
éditer vos vidéos ça c'est plutôt cool
et il ya un nouvel affichage aka
classement par l'intelligence
artificielle pour mieux avoir accès à
vos données en gros pour mieux avoir
accès à vos photos doit retrouver vos
souvenirs plutôt qu'hors des photos
story quelques pas et jamais savoir quoi
en faire
il ya aussi une évolution liée aux airs
pause lorsque vous recevez un message
que siri vous les messages de leurs
potes vous répondait directement et le
message part directement à votre
interlocuteur ça vous évite
effectivement d'avoir à prendre votre
smartphone d'apple votre message en
fasse un truc qui est assez marrant
assez intuitif et qui en tout cas devant
le bon sens par agde une évolution
intéressante au niveau du hall paul
lorsque vous arrivez chez vous vous avez
de la musique dans votre iphone vous
avez aimez vous le président votre en
mode et la musique continuera de se
jouer dans votre en pose donc pas
d'interruptions du point de vue en tout
cas expérience utilisateur se sentent
plutôt intéressante et petite nouveauté
qui mis bout à bout sont aussi
intéressantes
nouveauté également au niveau du quart
play apple dans votre voiture avec un
tableau de bord en réinventer plus
intuitif plus sympa avec toujours syrie
au milieu de ça et on a tout doucement à
ipad aux as qui est la grande nouveauté
qui pour moi est le plus intéressant
avec notamment des glisser déposer avec
un multitâche vous allez anneaux est
complètement adapté à votre ipad ça pour
le coup c'est bien toute une gestion des
fichiers que le team is et le partage
dossier dans claude en fallait pas mal
de choses
le fait de pouvoir notamment connecter
une clé usb une carte micro sd ou sdhc
fectivement partager vos données
directement depuis vos fichiers ça s'est
relativement intéressant safari
également adapté pour l'ipad les polices
complètement adapté une navigation qui
est améliorée et une latence qui
diminuait au niveau du style et on passe
de 20 millisecondes de latence à 9
millisecondes de l'attention plus tôt tu
as raison on arrive ensuite sur la
grosse annonce matériel sur le mac pour
alors le bac pro il est très
probablement pas du tout destiné pour
vous c'est vraiment une grosse bête de
combat destiné aux professionnels aux
personnes qui ont besoin de vous
beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de ressources de beaucoup de
puissance ils nous ont montré sur la
vidéo ou huit can multi moniteur un truc
qui est vraiment vraiment hallucinant
c'est en gros une machine complètement
modulaire flexible qui va tourner avec
un intel xeon processeur à 28 heures
enfin un truc complètement aux fous
furieux avec plein de portes tous les
côtés une machine qui vraiment évolutif
qu'on peut même mettre sur des roulettes
pour déplacer voyez le truc un peu vous
à côté de ça ils nous ont montré leur
nouvel écran c'est le pro display xdr on
ne connaissait le hdr high dynamic range
avec le x déroulée sur le extreme
dynamique pour age on va encore plus
loin plus puissant enfin ce qui est
vraiment fou furieux
un moniteur qui a coûté la bagatelle de
4 1999 dollars et un mac pro qui coûtera
la bagatelle de la version de base
d'entrée de gamme à 5999 dollars alors
très clairement je vous dis une fois de
plus n'est pas destiné pour vous c'est
vraiment un usage professionnel qu'on a
besoin de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
puissance pour le commun des mortels je
pense que ce produit là vous ne le
verrez
j'avais ensuite on arrive sur la mise à
jour de mac os
on allume aux abeilles dernière là on
est sûr catalina qui arrivera en juillet
de cette année nous on fait notamment un
focus sur itunes qui itunes disparaît au
revoir merci pour de nombreux et loyaux
services en gros c'est un petit peu
fourre tout c'est ce qu'ils disaient
avec itunes vous aviez accès à votre
musique vous avez accès à vos vidéos
vous avez laissé votre podcast bon je
pense qu'en fait c'est un petit peu
compliqué du point de vue utilisateur et
on n'utilisait pas forcément tous ces
services de la manière dont il faudrait
en tout cas on les utilise et peut-être
même pas du tout du coup ne sortent
trois applications dédiées apple musique
pour écouter toute votre musique apple
podcast est bien évidemment apple tv
on imagine que derrière il ya les
services qui correspondent et une autre
appelée intéressant qui vous permet
d'utiliser votre ipad comme moniteurs
supplémentaires avec votre mac
on n'a pas toujours des moniteurs
extérieur vous prenez votre votre ipad
pro pourrait modifier pouvait venir
écrire avec votre stylet ça parle sur
votre ordinateur enfin un truc est assez
intéressant à voir comment ça va être
intégrée peut-être que je le testerai
ultérieurement vous à du contrôle vocal
notamment pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite ou pour les personnes paralysées
tout est assez intéressant vous pouvez
tout commandées à la voix il ya tout qui
paraît en tout cas assez intuitif
vous connaissiez find my phone trouvé
mon iphone là vous avez fine maille
en gros vous d'y retrouver votre iphone
vous retrouvez votre mac quand il est
perdu l'idée c'est que lorsque vous
l'avez déclaré perdu elle va pouvoir
être détectable par tous les iphone à
proximité et les différents iphone pour
vous envoyer manière complètement
anonyme sécuriser la position exacte de
votre ordi ou de votre iphone pour
puissent les récupérer après nous en
montrer bien évidemment gros focus sur
la réalité augmentée on sait que tim
cook et apple croit beaucoup dans la
réalité augmentée vont dans ce sens là
nous fait une démonstration de minecraft
il n'y a rien de bien révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
les années précédentes
si ce n'est des petites évolutions en
tout cas on voit que ça va dans le sens
de l'évolution de la réalité augmentée
apple y croient ils croient plus en plus
bon un petit peu l'idée globale de tout
ce qui s'est passé je vous dis une
grosse annonce produit mais qui n'est
pas du tout fait pour grand public des
mises à jour de services qui semblent
intéressantes qui avance doucement n'y a
pas de grosses évolutions majeures mais
en tout cas apple progresse avant se met
à jour continues est dans la place et
avec un gros point fort sur la
sécurisation des données et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant dit pas ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commentaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez du parti-pris
d'apple sur la sécurisation des données
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils sont en
avance par rapport à facebook google est
ce que vous y croyez qu'elle est là non
ce qui vous est plus intéressé vous
marquez tout ça on va en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve dès demain
bonne nuit bonne journée en tout cas
pour moi il est tard il y en a une
couche et à bientôt ciao
[Musique]